wait what was it move on that's a lot
harder you're the lad Bible angle okay
I'm a cute guy you were at the lad Bible
I'm gonna sit here and answer a few
questions
how are usually very well man it's nice
to be able here to talk about something
that I had a such a great time making
and Dylan and this little film called
gold got in early went over and checked
on my good friend Woody Harrelson's who
just had a live feed of a film he wrote
produced and directed a live feed one
take one camera two 500 readers around
the world got in early for that and then
been speaking gold and sing for the last
two days so full film will be see a role
he put on listos focus we diet and how
long are exhausted a lot wait six months
whatever I wanted whenever I wanted it
my role was whatever you want to eat or
drink 24/7 you can say yes to and if you
second-guess yourself what kind of hey
you must have double so all of a sudden
I was 47 pounds heavier well and I
enjoyed all of it yeah yeah so lead the
way yeah was not sure a whole lot less
fun um yeah because quite a bit of what
I put on I noticed what I thought was
renting was renting to own so I had some
spots on me I was like that may be me
for the rest of my life um so now not as
much fun taking it off but it took about
five months to take it all off so you
kind of a beautiful thought I wrote my
much as Mike so what was your way she
becoming I get back to get back well
first had to kick-start it which meant I
went on seven days fast just to
kick-start my body to head back south I
mean you get older I noticed it's more
and more diet than using an exercise so
it was more about you know amounts of
food
bringing those down from three
cheeseburgers and a six-pack to you know
piece of fish it's a pasta salad and it
took a while and I was in a rush to get
it back down because I didn't have a
role that was that I had to be skinnier
for but I did have a role that needed to
be 45 pounds less for um so you both in
diesel know that do you have any advice
the guys who loses I have all kind of
skinny on so yeah man um there's a
couple ways to go I I had a silver
dollar bald spot here 18 years ago and
found this topical stuff called region X
which hasn't worked for anybody else
I've turned it on too but it's damn sure
work for me um and so every night I rub
my hair the surgery basically intended
my hair didn't come back
it came back so much so that a rumor got
spread that I had gotten hair
transplants and I talked to this guy who
did transplant I met him in the street
in Beverly Hills he comes up to me was
I've been hoping I would run into you
all my life ago I go because the last
ten years at the international hair
transplant convention we always put your
picture up on the slide and say who out
there did this man's hair transplant and
for seven years nobody raised their hand
he goes at the last three years there's
a Swedish doctors said I did it and I
started laughing though you didn't go
sky look at your hair you looked at my
roots because you haven't had hair
transplants I said no he goes I'm going
to bust that guy's balls the next year
at the next convention because I did not
have hair transplants the other thing is
you can go the way my friend Bob and
coops head he's a guy who was losing his
hair and all this friends were giving
him hell about it and all the sudden
shows up completely shaved and I said
what you do it for Bobby goes because
now I'm all faced baby
so just on another couple of white will
be play I'm sure detective I went to
market big project for a year already
would you ever consider when a professor
year old buckaroo season four season I'd
be open to it
I mean that script are so well written
and that characterize such I'd get any
man III that showed up again and was the
quality of that that first one I'd
definitely be open to it and so was the
one over film at the end of these two
fellows see to fly off trying to find
from would you look to kind of being and
Hinda sellers equals that'd be nice
haven't thought of that one any haven't
even spoken to mr. Nolan about that one
yeah this sort of setup for a possible
tiga Linden I'd sure consider that way
off he would lose rewards over the
proper years or walk forward for you
most are Kenny wells and gold is my
favorite character I've ever played
hangs down ah man I mean a such a life
force man I mean he they don't make many
movies about the king you elza's of the
world he's usually the sidekick or the
sidekick sidekick and this is a bio of
of a man who's at the bottom of the
barrel man who's not gonna who didn't
get a ticket to the American dream but
by hook or by crook is and I hustled his
way into the American Dream through the
side door the back door down the Dan
chimney and he literally chases a dream
yet he has a literal dream that he
chases by the one-way ticket to
Indonesia off a hot to watch and makes
it happen
so obviously those two little cheeky
monkey powder all that any kind of film
you paid in Italy run in your career so
you kind of look back on go across like
the racks what am i thankful not regret
because like in our scene
fortunately no I'm not arrogant enough
to be embarrassed about any of my past
work I mean I got to remember that me
like many people out there were trying
to try to act you take what works you
can get and be damned honored to be
going to work true when I first fell
into acting and you know I was doing it
having a great time that pay me three
hundred twenty-five dollars a day and
people were saying hey you pretty good
at this where you come back come on do
it some more
I was curious it as legal I was like I'm
really feel like I'm getting away with
something I still feel like I'm getting
away to come I know I am so there's
nothing in my past that I could do who
and say oh gee I can't believe I did
that
but I'm happy to be able to say that all
three Rockies alone so yeah so what was
your favorite I was fully hot I'm still
me
most fun filming well I've never had any
more fun and I did with Kimi Wells and
gold I'm gonna bring it up again even
though you haven't seen it we seen it
February 3rd hopefully um I had such a
good time with this role I mean it was
parts of one it was a true story too
there are a lot of parts of this guy
that was who I thought my dad was when I
was going on it was a lot of parchments
film for characters that my dad
introduced me to my dad would take me
around the country dry we drive go
office to office to people that owe him
money and a 12 year old if you bring a
12 year old along that can coerce some
people to pay me back and along those
road trips I would meet some characters
and it's been shady bill that my dad
would do the kidney wells of the world
and I just felt like I saw and
understood this guy from the inside out
from the get-go and I already miss him
you know
I'm miss Kenny I'm glad I'm glad he's
he's locked in film forever because I
should you like the guy who won't dream
who was not a lot this game rules yeah
we do yeah we do that now you know what
that is that's a relaxing technique
that's something I do just kiddin Kay
myself before a scene just to relax and
it was Leonardo's idea for me to put it
in the scene which I did so yeah I have
you have a different rhythm for
different roles but that one was a ready
going to dump you on camera you don't
get to him do it you see me do it okay
ready this I think we are almost on you
if you look to kind of sign off with
sure first words I ever said on film 27
years ago sitting in a 70 Chevelle
listening to Ted Nugent riding next to
Slater and shotgun going to pick up the
red head intellectual I knew I had three
out of four things that my man was about
and when they said action I said all
right I'll write I'll write pulled out
and got the fourth all right now